we are back uh to playing video games
today you know we got to keep playing
the video games because these videos on
the YouTube channel do really well they
get tens and tens of views generally
it's it's known that I'm not a a huge
video game fan although this one looks
interesting me in some ways it's right
up my alley this is Destroy All Humans
too this is a popular this is a popular
game right with the kids McKenna this is
is this a big game not exactly it's an
older game that was remastered last year
how old is this game it's originally
from 2006 I thought the whole playing
video games thing was like a was a you
know its way to freshen up the brand
bring in the youth but I'm playing a
game that no one under the age of 30
even wants to play but it's okay fine it
involves uh it involves aliens so I'm
interested in it and the objective I
assume is right there in the title is To
Destroy All Humans so as a misanthrop
myself and also as an alien believer
member of the ABC community
I'm feeling good about it I'm going
right to the hardest setting how hard
can it
be how do I skip press and hold
Circle you just have to press and hold
it there we
go you can't skip the loading screens
this G yeah this game is from the from
the 80s so of course it takes forever to
load
Premier comrade
me all right here we go so what am I
doing I'm just shooting them you just
skipped all the context who do I have to
shoot
anybody why is the I'm not even doing
that with the green
thing survive the Ambush kill the KGB
agents oh the bad guys are Russians of
course all right so who are the bad guys
the men in black suits and how do I kill
them by shooting I've gotten no hold on
a second I've gotten no instruction how
to play this game at all oh now I'm dead
already literally zero see if understand
they just put me down in this room with
this game and no one said anything to me
in general about anything just like hand
me the controller so I make a fool of
myself that's the only reason we're
doing this every single content idea
that you find on this channel is just me
looking like an idiot press L2 to aim
your gun how do I know which one is
L2
who okay so L2 to aim and then what am I
how do I shoot it's not you've already
been shooting everyone Matt okay who am
I aiming at kill the KGB agents you're
trying to kill the agents in black suits
the Asians in black suits agents is it
Asians or agents agents why would I be
killing Asians
agents this guy got him got
him
what is the objective where am I
supposed to go am I supposed to go
forward maybe if I knew what I was doing
kill the KGB agents stop ruining the
video you just tell me to stop ruining
the
video got him I'm on it well how do I
aim okay so L2 to
aim there we go that's a very
inefficient is there a quicker way to
kill them so I don't have to stay locked
on them for multiple seconds CU just
like a regular where I can shoot
them and I just
died I'm not ruining this
video all right see now I'm
learning is there a is there a more
efficient gun I can use me this is the
only one you get right
now am I supposed to kill oh that's not
a person that's
it well this is a how do
I
do you want to quit out and switch to an
easier difficulty Well yeah if that's an
option this is amazing content we are
changing the game with this you're going
to want to pick the recruit setting cuz
that's the easier setting yes well it
would have been good information to have
from the start I'm going right to the
heartest
S you know using the internet without
expressvpn is like walking your dog in
public without sec uring them on a leash
most of the time you'll probably be fine
but what if one day your dog runs away
or gets dog mapped it's better to be
careful especially when it's as simple
as using expressvpn every time you
connect to an unencrypted Network in
cafes hotels or airports Etc your online
data is not secured any hacker on the
same network can gain access to and
steal your personal data expressvpn
creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet so
they can't steal your data expressvpn
works on all your devices such as your
phone laptop tablet even on your smart
TV I love how easy it is to use
expressvpn just fire up the app click
one button to get protected it's that
simple your data is your business visit
expressvpn.com Walsh YT use my Link at
expressvpn.com Walt to get three extra
months free that's exp rsvpn
docomo
YT all
[Music]
right
I got the hang of
it all right that's
it so I'm just I'm just running forward
is all I'm
doing all
right where are you going Matt turn
around and go back no I'm just going up
here for a minute just going for a
stroll it's a lovely
afternoon don't cut any of
this m what are you doing exactly I'm
going to my
objective this this weapon sucks it's
it's the pro the problem is the weapon
and I'm supposed to believe that I came
all this way I've got all this Superior
technology that I'm able to travel
Lighty years across space and this is
the most efficient weapon that I have am
I supposed to killing that person yeah
which one this one this guy running away
come back here you son of a come back
here Matt you just have to kill the
Russians it says Destroy All Humans does
it not that's the name of the game you
have no
I'm so annoyed by this gun how do I even
aim it nobody knows how to
aim a lot of cardio in this game I got
to say I was expecting more out of this
game I thought I would enjoy it more if
you stop complaining and finish a couple
missions you'll get to be in a UFO I get
to be in a UFO can we just skip to that
level I I feel like I'm running around
in circles you're outside the mission
area go back to where you started well
now I'm going in slow motion what's
happening Mission
failed how is it failed Mission area
abandoned well mchan you told me to go
that direction so it's not even on me
all right we'll try this one more
time I don't know I'm just killing
everyone I don't know if I'm supposed to
kill them or not like this person here
should I kill her
no all right you don't want to kill the
innocent people I do want to to be clear
all right where's the that I get to fly
around in here you have to press R1 to
pick things up with your
mind what's
happening how do I direct my brain
energy can I skip this is that my
UFO CP to the mother ship all shut
up I need to bring in some big guns uh
nowhere I can get my hands on that's
what the alien sounds like okay so where
are the data this is the worst game ever
made no I don't want to I don't want to
talk to him I don't want to have any
conversation with this guy I just want
to get my UFO well I guess there's oh my
gosh oh there's no UFO this this is not
true strung me along this whole
time I got to say I was right about
video games though the whole time I've
had my moment I said I
retired there it
is oh this is a great segment idea I
love this I'm retiring from video games
this is the end of the segment I retired
after that moment and here I am
again came out of retirement at the age
of 35 Flawless Victory this
anti-climatic it's like when Jordan
retired from the Bulls and then shot up
on the Wizards I'm literally just
running around of circles shooting
random
people which you know it sounds fun in a
certain way but I could just walk up to
a
person and just shoot them like that the
next objective is right in front of you
huh on your
left now it's on your right
what now it's in front of you
what
here into the
fire what am I doing that's like an
octagon no that's a is there a diamond
on this it's the square button that's
it's like a no that's not a square
that's a what is it with the six
sides it's not a
pentagon hexagon is that a hexagon is
that with six sides there's no hexagon
on this thing just press the square
button see that's confusing why would it
be a hexagon if it's if they want you to
press
square oh there we go all
right and it's the slowest jetpack ever
made it's not even a jet pack this is
like a this is hand
gliding I get I give up I give
up all
right so are you sure you don't want to
keep trying and get the UFO no not
really I think I've seen enough of that
you don't want to live your UFO flying
dreams no I don't you don't I don't you
don't I don't I want to go home
so that was that video game thanks for
watching everybody I hope you enjoyed it
as much as I did we'll see you next
[Music]
time